bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
non vi sono prove j e oggi siamo l'altro
episodi di cioè spero sia avvenuta
perché se non è venuto ha fatto una
figura barbina di ragazzi oggi sono
fiero di introdurre una delle persone
più importanti come sice mia vita in
francese ed è perdente ma vi vienna i sì
ei cosa entrare mi dispiace
ciao fatto la spesa
sono molto contento più di tennis a
quando a vedere con questo cuore questa
è una figata pazzesca al dc però che per
l'occasione ha portato una maglietta
perfetta la maglietta perfetta perfetta
mi fai cambiare certo armani per far sì
che ci sono le [ __ ] beh la grandezza
del pacco introduce le tartarughe ninja
sonora per aprirlo sbirciatina pubblico
sbirciatina basta
ma io non so cosa c'è dentro a chi sa io
so idee ma è il tema è anni
no agli anni quaranta cosa suona gabry
ponte musica degli anni 90 ecco lo è ma
no che non va bene il tifo sotto
dell'inter come dell'inter ma chi ha
fatto la scatola questo suo ce l'avevo
tool giuro calma e morbido che trova
questa roba non solo le famose ricerche
come rompere un giocattolino nuovo flore
è arriva lui mai oggi dovrei pescato in
tavola
aspetto dalle forbici qua qua ne ho
bisogno e nato un nuovo zio nuovo zar
hai un fratellino lasciato qui va bene
teniamolo quali mentre che si schiude
folli polly pocket chi è polly pocket
all hip hop con ali portatile ma volli
pocket
e allora ho dato un pulcino adult renato
renato renato renato renato arda lonardo
è nato il tamagotchi lasciano lì che
sporca da solo ma è tutto da solo
indipendenza avesse apple i pochi io lo
so perché avevo un sacco di amiche
questa le facili fare le critiche
l'altalena la mitica
[Musica]
passiamo al prossimo
bella bella la nostra macchina che però
non costruiremo adesso ne va avanti con
questo secondo me non ho visto che ti
appartiene un botto dai fai vedere è un
libro sera non mi appartiene tutti cos'è
che paura dei ragni e cosa ti fanno
venire tib eccoli privi di bravo no è
fighissimo piccoli brividi che era tra
l'altro del nuovissimo vedono un altro i
piccoli velino è ma quale chi fa chi fa
le scatole simav a valle e vero ci
spetta cosa dovete comprati l'anno
scorso che le pene sono esaurite guardi
la ricordi la sua pistola gigante qui
non va nostra immagine legno valeria
inclusa ma sarei mangiar bene ma ok la
pistola che un cannone esatto ecco faida
guardia alta ma noi ci sei must faccio
una roba gigante alle primarie non su
un'altra cosa piccola noemi blade
oddio oddio zitti apriti schifoso faccio
io faccio faccio io
io questo lo so sei pronto e non ti farò
vedere la potenza dei beyblade vai ci
sei te nay alta lago ci vai robo.com hai
visto che forte che ha poteri
ecco sarebbe stata presa dai portale
vederlo rimanere il beyblade zio e i
bambini di oggi non sanno però i bambini
di oggi hanno la poké ball frontone xvi
a schiera way questa roba che cos'è a321
secondo me in due non ne facciamo uno al
gol al volo
trent'anni ha perso kakà a pacciana
faticando io non ci credo non ci credo
lorenzo cosa è scattato
vai il cappotto tutto sei pronto così 6
prontissimo e chiudono lo tiro fuori
penultimo mai relative fuori questo
vediamo se lo conosceva a el diablo che
però non ho mai usato vita minima
veramente eh sì perché porre in cima
caranza è avuto il loro microsoft è
bellissimo era un po da punkabbestia che
giocavano i bambini e poi ci giocavano
quelli con lui la sta male cena che
andavano al parco giocavano scuola si
giocava la destinazione è figure da
malore e cucinato al pesce non mi
ricordo bene il movimento poi era una
roba così
bravissimo è normale poi cerca di stare
in equilibrio possibile a farlo andare
un po tesa va bene va bene non pensavo
partisse così tanto ex minore ei figli
gli occhi e il cuore ei apri gli occhi
[Musica]
come il ciccio prete dall'umiliante
alberto angela si scava nei reperti
romani trova questa roba e mangiante lo
abbiamo lasciato una settimana in un
progetto archeologico a scavare la
trovate vedere è il mio arte che sta
facendo l'occhiolino e tipo 2 perché il
one a guardà cicciobello versione web e
che nel 2018
ciccio perché è il mio 19 non so quando
usciranno subito ha fatto azzera anni a
me parla come farla così guardano
le 37 il tp bocca e no traccia non parla
perché devi accenderlo qua si accende e
bello ce l'ha con te no no no mamma
della beata cioè con te allora papa
genitore 3
allora se facciamo le cose serie e
mezzogiorno dei vari brolo 1 vai col 1
impari a notte notte questa mia e sono
tali da allora spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto questo tuffo nel passato
negli anni 90 è stato sicuramente non
c'è anni 90 è un tema che non mi
aspettavo in abbozzi di la verità tra
tutti spero che ai video vi sia piaciuto
come al solito servito come al solito
servidone piaciuto lasciato il commento
fish eye anche vari social che quindi la
descrizione vi saluto anche cicciobello
fi ciao
anzi cicciobello più il video dai avola
noto a tutti
[Musica]